Before we start, Oscar nominations are officially out.
And if you're behind on your viewing, don't worry.
We've got entertainment tonight.
Kevin Frazier stopping by
on Friday, to tell us exactly what we need to watch.
Yes, they're all out there.
Oscar season is my favorite season of the year.
So can't wait for that?
But first, today, we're doing the news
declutter style and listen to this crazy statistic.
It's estimated that Americans have have 43 billion dollars
of old gadgets just sitting around the house.
And I, you know, I'm talking to you
'cause you got a flip phone and a ziplock bag
and a drawer somewhere.
Drew you had remotes in your junk drawer.
(audience laughing)
So I know, you know what I'm talking about
and USA Today reports, now you can get money for those items
on the Decluttr app and website.
So unlike sites like eBay, where you need to upload photos
and descriptions of your old stuff, this is so much easier
'cause you're selling to one company.
Here's how it works.
You sign up on their site,
you submit basic information on your items
what condition they're in old computers, old phones.
They're gonna to give you an offer, money.
And if you accept the offer, they take care of the shipping.
They're gonna buy your old electronics.
I have like five storage units.
Do you think they would take that?
They totally would.
But think about it.
So I try to, I try to pay my devices forward.
Like when I get a new phone or something
I'll give my own to my brother or wipe it clean.
But I, and I know I'm not alone.
I certainly have a drawer
of like two old computers I have to get rid of.
Yeah.
Yeah and this is a way maybe we could make a dollar
or something.
I have to say, I am doing a deep dive
on this Decluttr app because we all need this app.
It blew me away.
Next we're talking about after dinner cleanup
sometimes it's a real slog because you've already done
the delicious part, which is gung gung
(Ross laughing)
And then you just wanna like sit
in the juices of laziness and like, you know, digestion
but apartment therapy reports that the pizza were let cut
and surf board is here to help.
check this out.
It turns cleanup into a little game.
You serve your pizza on here.
And as each person takes a slice, guess what?
they reveal what their post pizza chore is.
And just like that, the pizza board has spoken.
I love this so much because whenever I'm eating
all I'm thinking about is like, Oh, I gotta do the dishes.
I gotta do that.
Now, it's like, you get assigned a chore.
I would like one of these slices to say
Ross you must walk around the block eight times
and stop eating pizza, put it down.
Great I'm gonna take a piece of pizza.
And then mine says, have another slice.
Oh man.
you won the pizza slice a lottery.
Can I just take a slice to see what my chore would be?
Yup
She doesn't like that.
(Ross laughing)
Oh my
Okay.
'cause I mentioned that Beautiful, the new company I have
is making a pizza cutter.
Isn't this cool?
That's a gorgeous pizza cutter.
I made it
You really did?
mhh
Yeah, can I take a piece for me to just see
what my chore would be?
If you dare.
I'm not gonna try it.
I just, it says.
Trade your chore.
Okay , so, so far drew and I don't have to do anything.
I know, we just have to eat more and like delegate.
I got the
Take out the trash
take out the trash.
Okay, there you go.
Turns out the, that pizza's trash, taking it out.
I don't know what
if a sponge
and like a jar of old tomato sauce had a baby.
There it is.
This is the first time I haven't wanted pizza.
Well, the wheel's a winner, everybody.
The wheel is good.
Yeah.
Lose the pizza.
(bright music)